[Music]
in fashion protests new submitted by
Ashley T a model staged the runway
protest against Gucci's use of
straitjackets straitjacket straitjacket
please don't tell me that somebody who's
like depressed is offended by straight
jackets yes you've never been in a
straitjacket beause you don't know how
it feels
jeez it's supposed to calm you down I
know I like it I get to cost to produce
exactly I can't breathe
I like your when it I put it on and I
get to relax and breathe because I just
start punching the walls you've worn a
straitjacket oh yeah wait how do you
punch the walls if your hands are like
exactly and then it prevents me from
punching the walls so just hugging
yourself that's pretty nice I don't like
it knowing that you can't like we need
been loving yourself all right the only
thing I would have a problem with is you
can't scratch itchy nose that's true
okay I can't scratch either yeah you can
no y'all ever heard of self suckers I'm
just saying okay so I tan Jones a 26
year old 9 bar non-binary model artist
and musician who uses they then pronouns
held up her hands are there their hands
on the runway to display a message that
read mental health is not fashion so it
is Gucci had you know how cool it is to
be bipolar oh [ __ ] yeah you should go
represent she was hired as a model and
in during the moon oh okay that would
happen if she wasn't even hired as a
model okay arrghh base are she where is
she like some kind of or is it a she or
she beat mama call her abhi hey then
i'ma call her up beep yeah yeah she's
non-binary then this is what she looks
like
no yeah but they look like that's right
that's what they look ah I'm so bad at
so I would get arrested in can never can
you remove that cuz I can't see a jack
[ __ ] oh yeah I know I was on there how'd
you read that oh my god yes what they
look like right there that the
protesters it's not even they
or there's their fight no but it's not
about non-binary penis it is their fight
because they were defending depression
and people that have mental health
issues and they basically are like the
straitjackets are like a symbol of
mental health and you're just making it
fashion and so you shouldn't be doing
that it's almost like the appropriation
of mental health is it like depression
and mental health here straightjacket is
like on the far side of the special
straitjacket is like I [ __ ] bit the
prison guard [ __ ] yeah this is like I'm
five percent Native American or like
even less point zero zero five percent
Cherokee yeah and I don't appreciate the
feathers yeah I think you're fighting
for something that's so far away from me
yeah like it yeah it's a big I'm so
tired of the whole fighting for stuff
that doesn't even apply to you like yeah
oh my god like when people are like this
is appropriation of black culture look
[ __ ] I only have a couple of race cards
I can play per year and if you play my
cards early it invalidates them later
when I need them [ __ ] you
yeah don't speak for me I speak for me
yeah yeah well you're helping the
oppression okay so she they say baby
should speak for themselves as an artist
and model who has experienced my own
struggles with mental health as well as
family members and loved ones who have
been affected by depression anxiety
bipolar and schizophrenia it is hurtful
and insensitive for a major fast fashion
house such as Gucci to use this imagery
as a concept for a fleeting fashion
moment or [ __ ] you can normalize it by
making it mainstream fashion there's so
many perspectives through and then also
okay so oh so they were inspired to
protest after one of the models that was
hired to be in the show last minute
decided to drop out because they were
really offended by the straitjackets -
mm-hmm but the real question is what day
to look cool it did I'm not sure well
you could decide for yourself it looks
cool so that's what matters to me yours
uh what I wish I could make this bigger
but I can't so
this is it looks future this is what
they looked like like brings overalls
yeah it's not a real straight jacket
yeah I wanted to see models come out
like this like major problem with this
like when people say like oh this is
appropriation in some way of shape or
form it's when the the object is coveted
by the culture or the person because
people with mental health issues and
ever been like my straightjacket it's
not something that they take great pride
in a father it's like a bad thing like
nobodies I own my straitjacket my choice
like that is not what's [ __ ]
happening dude like that this is such a
waste of everybody's time the other
thing is from in my opinion fashion is
art you know it's yeah is like making a
statement like when you're doing these
fashion shows that people write garbage
bags and stuff like pression helps you
more be more creative and artistic -
yeah so really that's available - yes
yes but so the designer was like I
wanted to depict how society today can
have the ability to confine
individuality and that Gucci can be the
antidote for me the show was a journey
from conformity to freedom and
creativity so the wasn't even like the
straitjackets weren't part of the
fashion pieces so what designers usually
do is they have like these like crazy
like almost like art installation
wardrobe pieces come out like concept
art yeah and then they have like like
show they write after yeah so these were
like this wasn't even part of the
designers line I really wanted to see
some models come out in straightjackets
and it's like that's all they're wearing
yeah
dude what about music videos where like
like asylums are depicted people and
straight like where how about you go to
that you know like really you just
picked one random I'm so there's that
one N Sync video whether they're like in
like that room where it's all the song
was that I don't know but I remember
they were
M&Ms have one they call Taiwan I know
Eminem did when to know his like why do
people even listen to this [ __ ] dude I
can't because people are waiting to get
triggered because to me when I read a
lot of this [ __ ] I'm like aren't you
embarrassed that you're taking your own
interpretations of art and then making
it as if its objective that's what I'm
saying like so you could never paint
anything except for like sunshine and
rainbows right well you can't do that
you can't do that either I'm happy
that's mine I know you a sad because if
someone uses something Japanese in their
art and I don't understand it
I asked the artist for their motivation
or why they did what they did or
whatever to try to see what the intent
behind well instead of being like oh
that's that's just [ __ ] taking my
[ __ ] because I don't even own it I'm
even at that point you know as an artist
you don't have to answer [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] you could just be like this is my
art accept it or not because really it's
about it's about causing the
conversation exactly this kind of stuff
happens maybe that's what they want
yeah yeah well I think like there's also
this like need to have people tell you
you're brave for something you know in
my opinion there's like a lot of people
that like will do something you know
what it'd be brave is to try to shut
down non-porn because that's
appropriation right there or they take
you to somebody
yeah sacrilegious yeah like the Mormon
orgies yeah it's like that's sacred to
somebody somebody's a good point show
that is you should take a stand I don't
be really brave I don't like none porn I
like nurse I liked nurse Portmore report
sometimes they look too old nation is
mad weird man word girl Mormons look
like no they just looked like normal
creepy white people that live in caves
well Kayden slugs plays she knows the
exact she had to play this here to play
the website I feel like none porn is
there so that guys that get caught by
their girlfriends watching porn um
they're like you watching porn and then
be like none
that that's pretty good but fast-forward
to the part where they're worshipping
yeah I didn't like they get into
confession and then they get into the
[ __ ] what the pastor opens and he's
like I can't take this [ __ ] anymore
and then they have sex don't show that
part to the girlfriend like porn where
there's little buddies like at three
minutes and seven minutes that it's like
not porn so if somebody walks in you can
just hit that time code yeah you got to
still pull up your pants and do all that
so with this with the the fashion show
like so like I've had depression and
anxiety like I still have that like I'm
diagnosed with that but I for me I
didn't see this as being offensive
I think it's art I feel like I but I
also wouldn't speak for everybody with
depression or anxiety I feel is it the
same way for you where you're talking
about earlier or like someone else is
speaking for you yeah no absolutely but
this person like are they bored yeah are
you born
they sound like someone without any real
struggles in life like you're just
ruminating about [ __ ] that's like
seriously man that's like getting angry
at how crispy a mcdonald french fry is
yeah that's pointless to me well
actually I don't like the crispy ones
there that makes sense though but she
once I take that back that's a serious
issue we could share fries do you have
the crispy I'll take the mushroom oh
I'll take it you like the ones at the
bottom like the very like the sword
fries oh yeah yeah potato chip one
stabbed a time out the stuff yeah they
said presenting these struggles as props
for selling clothes in today's
capitalist climate is vulgar
unimaginative and offensive to millions
of people around the world it's so
fashionable to be a socialist right now
- it's so funny okay and they're like
and they're like it's I'm gonna take a
stand for these people that can't speak
up because I can't imagine do it to me
okay I could be wrong on this but I'm
just gonna throw my two cents out there
and what I think it is I think that
these are people there early in their
life they felt powerless to an extent
like they either felt trapped in their
bodies or they couldn't express their
sexuality or you know other things were
kind of put onto them and they felt
helpless they felt powerless but now the
Internet
this platform they have this voice and
they're so excited that finally they're
heard because they weren't heard when
they're children or teens but they're
kind of abusing it they're lashing out
against the people that oppressed them
it's only when people are talking about
all this like hate toward women or men
or whatever they're really talking about
their mothers their ex-girlfriends their
ex-boyfriends whoever personally hurt
them and then but then the rest of the
world is getting [ __ ] for it yeah this
is the psychology Cornwell and at the
same time like there's pockets and
there's big pockets in the art world
where like everyone's really pretentious
and they think that's the [ __ ] that they
think and that yeah their opinions are
the most important everyone that's not
following suit is a [ __ ] mic and
they'll get up follow the small x
mattering of people that are like yeah
yeah great so she was called brave and
then she goes this sort of bravery
you're an idiot she goes they go this
sort of bravery is only a simple gesture
compared to the bravery that people with
mental health issues show every day
Oh Avery to get out of bed to greet the
day and to live their lives as an app is
an active strength and I want to thank
being here and being known all the
people suffering from mental depression
and you know I've got a really is like
you know they need to be commended for
being brave or they need to feel power
this type of thing hour is free board
any relies on audiences applauding you
and so when no one's applauding you
you're gonna do more you're gonna do
more you're a shock jock yeah yeah like
where does that leave you in ten years
although Gucci did get in trouble last
year for these blackface I thought that
was a cartoon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]